the New York Times reports that while  the Department of Housing and Urban  Development was planning to cut programs  for the homeless elderly and the poor it  spent 31 thousand dollars on a new  dining set for secretary Ben Carson's  office the custom set included a  hardwood table chairs and hutch a former  top HUD official says she was demoted  and transferred for resisting attempts  to get around a law that requires  congressional approval for redecorating  costs over $5,000 a HUD spokesman says  Carson didn't know the table had been  purchased he does not believe the cost  was too steep and does not intend to  return it there's a big difference  between five and 31,000 there is there